welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm pairing cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today
earlier we talked a lot about some of
the craziness coming out of the state of
Texas the Board of Education Ted Cruz
but you know Florida Florida always
tries to give Texas a run for their
money on who can be just the weirdest
state in the country or the most corrupt
or the most vile and I don't think that
Texas has anything on current Florida
Governor current Republican Senate
candidate rick scott rick scott is
absolutely one of the worst politicians
in the united states today this is a man
who long before he ever had a career in
politics was running a health care
company and they committed one of the
largest Medicare frauds in the history
of the United States in fact at the time
it was the largest over a billion
dollars and he had to plead the fifth
amendment more than 74 times to avoid
implicating himself in a crime and
knowing that this state still voted for
him twice as our governor and guess what
folks he brought that same level of
corruption that he had in business to
our government down here in the state of
Florida now he thinks that that
corruption is gonna propel him to a US
Senate seat to unseat Democrat Bill
Nelson this week Rick Scott basically
got chase out of a campaign stop because
of protesters and these people were
there protesting the massive red tide
that we're currently having throughout
our state on both the Gulf Coast and the
Atlantic coast we have dead marine
animals including dead marine mammals
dolphins
we got Turtles everything washing up
dead all over our shores tourism has
taken a massive hit which is this
state's number one source of economic
activity beaches are being shut down in
some areas the red tide is so bad that
if you go
close enough to the water and breathe in
you will get sick not can will and Rick
Scott has been governor throughout all
of this so when he was out of campaign
stop the other day for his Senate race
he was met by a bunch of protesters and
he was so terrified that he actually
entered through the back of the
restaurant where he was doing his little
stop and stayed for less than ten
minutes because the chance of hey hey ho
ho
red tide rick has got to go those cheers
chants from those protestors chase rick
scott from that campaign stop and
hopefully they're gonna chase them all
around this state because that's what
needs to happen rick Scott right now and
I know you don't see if you're not
living in the state of Florida luckily I
am so I'm subjected to it daily is
running campaign ads actually blaming
the red tide on Bill Nelson saying that
because Bill Nelson works in Washington
DC that he somehow is the one who
controls the flood waters and the dams
in the southern part of Florida which is
where the red tide originates and it's
his fault that even happened now that's
a really seriously twisted look on
reality but here's what happens ladies
and gentlemen each year Lake Okeechobee
down in Florida biggest lake in the
state the rainy season comes the lake
overflows they vent it out there is a
lake excuse me a river running from
Okeechobee to the Gulf and one running
from Okeechobee to the Atlantic
Okeechobee is heavily polluted the sugar
industry dumps a lot of toxins in there
they've got a lot of power in the state
so they're allowed to do it those toxins
help breed the algae and other bacterias
so when we vent that Lake out into the
Atlantic and the Gulf creates a red tide
now there were already algae blooms
because of the warm warmer than usual
waters in the Atlantic and Gulf had
massive our algae blooms already and
when it met with the algae coming from
Okeechobee it created this massive
disaster we're seeing today
rick scott's trying to blame it on bill
nelson bill nelson has done a very poor
job of explaining to voters in the state
of florida that rick Scott as the
governor cut seven hundred million
dollars from the state's environmental
budget and he cut back the government
agency that's actually in charge of
water quality and preventing things like
this from happening you can't blame the
entire red tide on rick Scott but I
venture to say that you could probably
blame about 90% of it on rick Scott
through his environmental and budget
cuts because had he not done that this
entire disaster could have been 100%
preventable